leben auf dem sozialen existenz minimum
reduziert wie viel geschafft und hat nur
plagt doch kritiker sagen die
sozialhilfe sei zu hoch
[Musik]
man muss keine steuern zahlen
beim us chronik zahlen medizin das
vorurteil dass ein erfurt mit der
sozialen krankenkassen
das zahlt alles sozial und denn konzept
vielleicht viel besser mit der familie
die sozialhilfe ist politisch unter
druck geraten
treibende kraft ist die svb
[Musik]
das darf mit interessanten der
sozialhilfe liebe die sozialhilfekosten
drücken aufs budget der gemeinden in den
kantonen sind radikale
kürzungsvorschläge hängig
[Musik]
ohne dass malware ohne dass man sich
bewusst was das heißt um die sozialhilfe
tobt ein politischer kampf ist sie zu
bequem für die betroffenen und zu teuer
für die allgemeinheit
wie sieht die realität aus und warum
will eines der reichsten länder der welt
bei den ärmsten sparen
[Musik]
karin geräusch 44 sozialhilfeempfängerin
es haben jede idee
danke das trifft nur die andere
das war sehr stark und menschen wie mini
familie mit schwindet einfach aus
nämlich sind im alltag nicht wirklich
sichtbar hätten sozialhilfe karin orange
ist alleinerziehende mutter von vier
kindern
kian der jüngste ist behindert ein
drittel aller sozialhilfebezüger sind
kinder die familie wohnt in moosen am
hallwilersee hier gibt es günstige
wohnungen bis das dritte kind zur welt
kam hat karin orange als
behindertenbetreuer hingearbeitet dass
man muss an meister merkte ich dass er
umgangssprachlich wasserkopf zeit mit
dem hüter der fall wäre das anschaut im
köpfchen wasser gut ableiten ist für
autismus hat er seit kurzem ist kilian
drei nächte pro woche im internet
trotzdem will karin roche keine arbeit
suchen
das wird nicht das musikmachen der
sozialdienst akzeptiert diese begründung
[Musik]
karin dor scheine von rund 278.000
sozialhilfe bezügerinnen und bezügern in
der schweiz
das sind 3,3 prozent der bevölkerung
alleinerziehende sind eine wachsende
gruppe in der sozialhilfestatistik es
spiegelt sich der gesellschaftliche
wandel
wer sozialhilfe bezieht spricht nicht
gern darüber schon gar nicht vor der
kamera
karin orange aber will reden
stellvertretend für viele trinken kaffee
aus kapseln und flog mit
das muss alles plant wird das muss ich
bin schon anfangs monate damit ich plane
mit 14 zog beliebt und selbst mit nimmt
also sicht immer noch und dann ja ich
möchte hat media und macht aktivitäten
für die jungs
es stellt im garten auf und ab und zu
mal im garten übernachten
natürlich karin dor schläft im
wohnzimmer die fünfköpfige familie mit
zwei töchtern im teenager-alter lebt auf
dem sozialen existenzminimum die 200
franken und bedarf der hand für das ist
und mir die und krankenkasse wird ihnen
dazu berechnet
aber zum essen zum labor dass der betrag
alimente und hilflosenentschädigung
gehen direkt an sozialamt karin orange
bleibt nur der grundbedarf für fünf
personen sind das 2000 380 franken gut
15 pro tag und person für lebensmittel
kleider handy zug und bus zum beispiel
für eine person liegt der grundbedarf
bei 986 ist dieser betrag zu hoch oder
zu tief das ist die politische frage
[Musik]
danke
die diskussion um kürzungen macht karin
dor aus angst es lange glaubt wirklich
zu machen und mich wirken schmid und das
auch mit 40 die sozialhilfe einst als
fürsorge für die ärmsten im land gedacht
ist unter beschuss geraten
tatsächlich sind die kosten in wenigen
jahren von 1,7 auf 2,6 milliarden
franken gestiegen
sie will radikal kürzen
der svp gemeindepräsidentin und
ehemaliger sozialvorsteherin von
ladenburg und kanton zürich
das ist miss sorgst du tust bin ich
trikot und natürlich viel
ungerechtigkeit festgestellt theres
leppersdorf hat 1100 einwohner seit 25
jahren wohnt sie in hagen buch das
dorfleben sei hier noch intakt sagen die
einheimischen
zwei beizen hat es in haben buch eine
hauptstraße mitten durchs dorf einen
lebensmittelladen ein paar
kleinunternehmen und
landwirtschaftsbetriebe
vor fünf jahren wurde die idylle gestört
theres schlepper gab den medien offen
auskunft über die sozialhilfekosten der
gemeinde
auslöser war eine siebenköpfige familie
aus eritrea von sozialer irrsinn und
exorbitant hohen kosten war die rede
die geschichte lief aus dem ruder teresa
musste präzisieren
denn längst nicht alle sozialhilfekosten
der familie musste die gemeinde tragen
trotz der misstöne damals die
gemeindepräsidentin würde wieder gleich
handeln ps schlepper ist nicht allein
sie gehört zu einer svp arbeitsgruppe
welche die sozialhilfe umkrempeln will
der kopf der ageh sozialhilfe alt
nationalrat ulrich schlüer
[Musik]
ulrich schlüer hält die fäden zusammen
und organisiert alle paar monate an
treffen heute im parteisekretariat der
svp zürich in dübendorf
also angefangen hat sie festgestellt
haben dass die frank vor der steigung
zum teil explosion von der sozialhilfe
rechte dass die große unruhe ausgelöst
dann habe ich festgestellt dass in der
svp so und so viele frauen und männer
sind wo die ihr gemeint mit der frank
mehr oder weniger stark zum teil sehr
stark konfrontiert sind
so entstand die arbeitsgruppe
sozialhilfe über 20 svp mitglieder aus
der deutschschweiz sind darin vertreten
an diesem abend will man einen
sonderparteitag auf nationaler ebene
vorbereiten
nicht alle wollen sich filmen lassen zu
heikel heißt es die gruppe will einen
abbau der sozialhilfe einen masterplan
gibt es nicht dafür viele idee vorstöße
aus dem baselbiet geben die richtung vor
aber ausgerechnet der verfasser fehlt
heute peter regli baselbieter svp
landrat hat die schweizweit radikalste
forderung aufgestellt er verlangt dass
der grundbedarf bei allen
sozialhilfebezügern um 30% auf absolute
existenzminimum gesenkt wird das
bedeutet eine umkehr des systems heute
gilt der grundbedarf von 986 franken
kann bei sozialhilfeempfängern die nicht
kooperieren um 30 prozent gekürzt werden
der vorschlag von svp-mann riebel das
gegenteil alle sozialhilfebezüger sollen
unten anfangen und nur wer kooperiert
kriegt wieder mehr
motivation statt repression so der titel
der vorschlag hatte erfolg die motionäre
wurde mit unterstützung der fdp knapp
gutgeheissen
die kantonsregierung baselland muss
handeln der baselbieter landrat an die
brüssel steht voll hinter den vorstoß
das scheine vor der waage
es darf nicht lukrativ sind sozialhilfe
bibel kritik dass die schlimmsten aber
das interessiert jetzt sagen ich würde
etwas der regierungsarbeit und hat uns
im land rote mann ist es war nicht meine
stärke
das würde 30% ausland derart teil 60
prozent aus landes sozialhilfe was er
könne mir meist doppelt so viel wie man
bewohnern und mit deinem grundbedarf an
besetzte komödie sozialgerichts gesehen
und hätte gegen sportvorstand mit dem
ganzen das wird sich denn wieso soll ich
jetzt nicht sagen
es geht darum dass man sie stehen hier
sind interessant ist dass biber das land
es geht nicht nur ums sparen
ziel ist es die sozialhilfe so unbequem
wie möglich zu machen
zudem stört sich die arbeitsgruppe an
der höhe des gesamten sozialhilfe
betrags also grundbedarf plus miete und
krankenkasse
[Musik]
es gibt sie die familien mit so hohen
bezügen
laut bundesamt für statistik machen
familien mit zwei und mehr kindern 5,9
prozent aller fälle aus wie die
forderungen für den nationalen
sonderparteitag genau aussehen ist zu
diesem zeitpunkt noch unklar
einig sind sich aber alle hier in diesem
raum so kann es mit der sozialhilfe
nicht weitergehen
in bern treffen wir felix wolffers co
präsident der schweizerischen konferenz
für sozialhilfe skos in der skos sind
alle kantone und viele gemeinden
vertreten mit kürzungsidee kann er gar
nichts anfangen
grossarth wirtschaftsentwicklung
geschafft habe vielleicht schlecht
qualifiziert über gesundheitliche
probleme und mit denen lüth sieben
bisher im app store ist sie und es
bricht die solidarität auf und trieb er
ist ganz eindeutig dass volvo versucht
die solidarität sprechens gründer mini
quasi wie wenn wir die lupus
gesellschaftlich das volk psychische
probleme mit kriminalität und das kann
nicht wahr
ich frage mich was steckt eigentlich
hinter den erzählt auch wolfers ist
besorgt über die kosten zunahme in der
sozialhilfe
ein bericht des bundes liefert erklärung
so sind die ausgaben für
und krankenkassen stark gestiegen was
sich in der sozialhilfe niederschlägt
und auch wenn die zahl der
sozialhilfebezüger prozentual kaum
gestiegen ist so hat das
bevölkerungswachstum doch eine zunahme
der fälle bewirkt
in hagenbuch seien die sozialen für
kosten in den letzten jahren stets
gestiegen sagt gemeindepräsidentin
theres schnitzer 16 personen beziehen
hier sozialhilfe das sind weniger als
zwei prozent der einwohner für die
betreuung zuständig ist yvonne ball
seit acht jahren ist sie sozial
sekretärin in hagenbuch sie ist
kontrollinstanz coach und betreuerin in
einer person hätte schlüsselstelle ich
danke meinen tisch mit ihrer stadt und
betreuung von meinem konto der klientin
will see macht die betreuung intensiv
gewinns private halter kenntnis und ganz
praktisch fix vermögen ist es für die
person machen der sich das 4 1 über rot
jetzt alles von mir wissen und machte
schritt wenn geld und den boden so viele
unterlagen wohne ich halt so auch die
kompliziertesten mal drin aber das ist
immer ganz wichtig einmal aufgenommen
gilt die kooperations pflicht sozial
sekretärin ball macht nicht nur gute
erfahrungen wie meine chance ich frage
nach der klienten der verhalten zu
machen und das in den apps und umso
sicherer unterwegs ist und dass ich
etwas kühler das geordnet ist wiederum
gegangen
samstag wartet nun der termin noch mit
zahlen und das sind sachen wonach er
widerspiegelt
und was machen wir dann halt kurz oder
das hört sich ja eigentlich schon
aber wenn ich habe mich natürlich dass
ich genau hilfe und viel ist über jahre
als ich eigentlich müsste aber nicht
finanziell
folgen sie seit meine stimme sozietät
mit dem gesetz das nicht so einfach
unbürokratisch machen
[Gelächter]
der sozialdienst den haben buch und in
bar
hier betreuen gut 70 sozialarbeiter 6500
klientinnen und klienten
[Musik]
felix wolffers ist neben seinem amt bei
der skos auch chef des stadtberner
sozialamts löste die finanzielle und
personelle situation in bern gibt es
spezialisierte teams für junge
erwachsene für suchtproblematik oder für
leute die wenig betreuung brauchen wie
alleinerziehende mütter auf einen
sozialarbeiter kommen hier im schnitt
100 sozialfälle in allen städten ist die
quote der sozialhilfeempfänger höher als
auf dem land das fordert andere
strukturen das meer differenziere er
noch beratungsbedarf aus der junge
erwachsene ist 10 und tragen darum
steine dass die roosevelt ich mache und
der time reduziert die fallzahlen des
e-business sozialarbeiter stellen und
dort ist eigentlich relativ intensiv
betreuung möglich jeder andere teams
natürlich weniger intensiv
sozialarbeiterin reiner bremm betreut
erwachsene ab 25 kilian steffen steckt
mit 28 jahren in einer lehre als
polymechaniker für diese zeit ist er auf
sozialhilfe angewiesen dass sich das
projekt von soziales noch das gibt es
bei mclaren f1 pro jahr und da immer
egal wie viele bewohner im haus hat was
er für bank kommt die dem kontoauszug
oder letzten die letzte kritik technik
und und und
die wahl schon von anderen druck wachsen
und ein bisschen verschieben
die eltern können finanziell nicht
helfen lehrlingslohn und stipendien aber
reichen nicht ganz die sozialhilfe
überbrückt eine investition in die
zukunft ist nicht das wahre
auch der kanton bern spart in der
sozialhilfe es ist der erste kanton der
sich beim grundbedarf nicht an die skos
richtlinien hält und acht prozent
gekürzt hat das letzte wort hat nun das
volk
ich lernte die das taten die häuser
tiroler damit dann wenn man gründlich
gedanken daran dass neben so sagen
und jetzt wird es wird druck war enorm
und findet so gut
ein fall aus dem kanton aargau zeigt wie
gemeinden schon heute kürzen können am
kantonsspital hat sich monika sind von
einer römer spezialisten untersuchen
lassen auf geheiß des sozialamts
diagnose hat sie noch keiner dass ich
nachdem monika sind schmerzen sind
chronisch die arbeit als kassieren hat
sie deswegen längst aufgegeben
sieben jahre war sie schon in der
sozialhilfe als das sozialamt letzten
juni neue medizinische abklärungen
verlangt per verfügung obwohl sind erst
gerade von brustkrebs genießen war
das sozialamt ihrer wohngemeinde
oberentfelden will klären ob sie ein
wirklich aus medizinischen gründen nicht
arbeiten kann und sie fordert dass die
klienten in eine günstigere wohnung
zieht
wenn wir dort plötzlich verlangt jetzt
dass sie zur zeremonie des mülls das
wäre für mich will den mist ich weder
evonik finden
honig honig starker und ca das wäre
vielmehr katastrophe der ganzen welt
zusammen
das kann nicht von maza
die gemeinde will zum fall seien nicht
direkt stellung nehmen weil er noch
hängig sei aber wie erfahren warum es
eine neue verfügung gegeben hat im
sozialamt wurde personell aufgestockt
und nicht kopiert oder wenig kooperativ
sind war der sozialhilfe leicht gekürzt
es sind enorme feuchte wo meter
mittragen und das tut einfach weh
[Musik]
monika sens drei zimmer wohnung kostet
1.000 und 23 franken und lag schon immer
über der mietzins richtlinie der
gemeinde die im letzten jahr noch einmal
gesenkt wurde von 900 auf 850 franken
damit ist monika science wohnung 173
franken zu teuer
bisher trug das sozialamt die mehrkosten
jetzt wird ein strich gezogen wenn sie
nicht umzieht muss sie selber für die
differenz aufkommen
monika senn will die verfügung nicht
akzeptieren
[Musik]
die haben bucher gemeindepräsidentin
theres schlepper ist überzeugt das ist
druck braucht die sozialhilfe sei zu
attraktiv der grundbedarf von 986
franken pro person könne problemlos um
ein drittel gesenkt werden
für ihre familie kauft schlepper indoor
schlagen ein was mir wertete grundbedarf
ich denke ich würde zwar keine tore also
ewig sagt frank bohmann monat lang auf
schritt und der ist dreifache mutter und
hat immer teilzeit gearbeitet meist bei
ihrem mann im geschäft jetzt ist die
ehemalige freibad endend zu 20 prozent
als gemeindepräsidentin tätig
[Musik]
die gemeindepräsidentin nimmt unseren
vorschlag auf und wird persönlich prüfen
was es heißt mit einem gekürzten
grundbedarf zu leben
auch felix wolffers ist je nach fall für
druck kontrolle und sanktionen
stolz ist wolf haas aber auf die
bemühungen der stadt bern die
sozialhilfe bezüge wieder zu integrieren
der leiter des sozialamts führt uns zu
einer der velo stationen am bahnhof hier
erhalten sozialhilfe empfänger die auf
den ersten arbeitsmarkt keine chance
haben eine tagesstruktur seit kurzem
arbeiten auch vorläufig aufgenommene
asylbewerber hier migrationsbereich
früher oder später sozialhilfe und mir
finde es wichtig dass sie möglich früher
mit der arbeitsweise die kompakttraining
de rossi angebot darf eröffnet und die
hier gezielt dass man sie über die ich
beschäftige delany samadi ist einer von
aktuell 3 asylbewerbern die hier einen
job haben
samani kommt aus afghanistan und ist
seit drei jahren in der schweiz
mittlerweile ist er vorläufig
aufgenommene ausländer noch übernehmen
seine sozialhilfekosten bund und kanton
wenn er in ein paar jahren keine arbeit
findet muss der sozialdienste gemeinde
übernehmen gelernt wirtschaft würde
längst nicht alle packen so an wie die
lisa marie vor allem leute die der
sozialdienst der stadt bern vermittle
hätten manchmal probleme und seien
unpünktlich sagt martin schachel sachen
die gar nicht und es ist heute in jena
heute in jener bringe noch nicht wer von
morgen
dass mein geschäft schwierig wenn etwa
der worte einfach nicht fertig aber ja
das trifft ja melanie samadi hat
feierabend
er sei zufällig in der schweiz gelandet
habe flüchten müssen wegen des krieges
und der taliban sagte er
den genauen grund kennt nur das
migrationsamt seit einem halben jahr
wurde nun in niederschelden einem vorort
von bern sommer die wohl zusammen mit
wally heidel
auch er ist aus afghanistan und seit
drei jahren in der schweiz und auch sehr
freuen
etwa 640 kennengelernt haben sich die
beiden afghanen im asylzentrum delany
ist 25 wally 27 jahre alt
nur wenn man danke ich auch ich bin ich
stolz auf dich sicher haben sie leben ja
jetzt noch von der sozial 400 franken
kommen und wie geht das
es geht wenn das als vorläufig
aufgenommene ausländer erhält samadi 412
franken für den grundbedarf im
asylbereich sind die ansätze generell
tiefer als in der regulären sozialhilfe
zusätzlich bekommt zur magie für seine
arbeit in der velostation 561 franken
bald will er eine lehre antreten und
mehr verdienen
kollege wally hat es bereits geschafft
und ist weg von der sozialhilfe seit
kurzem arbeitet er in einem altersheim
das ist außergewöhnlich über 80 prozent
der asylbewerber leben von der
sozialhilfe mehr druck sei nicht falsch
sagen beide
das ist ganz wichtig wenn jemand in der
schweiz bleiben muss diese sprache
lernen im gegensatz zu anerkannten
flüchtlingen wurde die sozialhilfe bei
asylbewerbern und vorläufig
aufgenommenen vor drei jahren gekürzt
luzern hier will karin orange billig
einkaufen mit dabei ist einer der hunde
die sie in freiwilligenarbeit für eine
tierschutzorganisation betreut
eine stunde dauert die zugfahrt von
moosen hierher
ja es nicht einfach viel zu viel die
monatlich bis zweimal der caritas markt
verkauft vergünstigt ware die für die
reguläre kundschaft nicht mehr in frage
kommt je nachdem also das kind gern hand
wenn man sie aber geschrieben produkte
und so aber schüsse ins auto natürlich
ohne den günstigen wird auch dazu hand
freut aber nicht nur wer nachweislich am
ist darf hier einkaufen
es braucht eine bescheinigung
[Musik]
das thema sparen beherrscht den alltag
terrys schlepper hat inzwischen
eigenhändig berechnet was ist täglich
braucht zum überleben für einen tag
rechnet schlepper total mit 12 franken
50 für essen und trinken pro person
den restlichen bedarf für den
lebensunterhalt berechnet sie noch hinzu
und unterbietet gar das absolute
existenzminimum von 690 franken kosten
wie strom oder mobilität hat sie
allerdings außer acht gelassen situation
das ist eine klare und denselben auch
helfen das ist auch klar aber der betrag
dass man auch mit einem drittel weniger
von 186 franken guter hund
rückfahrt vom caritas markt
wir geben karin der roche die
einkaufsliste die theres schlepper
zusammengestellt hat einen franken 56
morgen 6 franken 50 und 3 franken 05 für
die nacht und mit dem einkaufen mit
theres schlepper bald soll dieser wunsch
in erfüllung geht
monika senn hat zum teil recht bekommen
mit ihrer beschwerde das sozialamt müsse
rücksicht nehmen auf ihre chronischen
schmerzen und die kündigungsfrist
beachten
doch der umzug in eine günstigere
wohnung ist unumgänglich wenn du dich
auch außerhalb der gemeinde keine
sozialhilfe empfänglich beiden inserat
mit ruhm hat mit der centropa wird über
das ist also eine hilflosigkeit
schon im frühling 2020 kommt monika senn
ins pensionsalter mit ahv und
ergänzungsleistungen könnte sie sich die
bisherige wohnung leisten
die gemeinde aber will konsequent
bleiben
es geht richtlinien und dort immer
natürlich vom jüngsten bis zum ältesten
wie ich behandelt der einzelnen fall von
sozialhilfe bezüger wer tagen wirkt das
eher besser dasteht in der
privatwirtschaft sieht die maßnahmen
oder die zutreffend oder tropfen hält
sieht die rustenburg sahen das schwierig
zu sagen weil so viel mit sozialhilfe
fall dazu sind ist es natürlich sagen
dass man die fristen könnte st aber man
hört und jede schraube macht können
jeglicher und der wenig gekostet
die medizinische diagnose die das
sozialamt verlangt hat ist für monika
sind ungünstig ausgefallen
sie sei zu 100 prozent arbeitsfähig wenn
sie sich am arbeitsplatz bewegen können
die gemeinde prüft ob sie monika senn in
die arbeitsintegration schicken will
in ihrem alter sind die chancen auf dem
arbeitsmarkt verschwindend klein
die zahl der älteren menschen in der
sozialhilfe hat sich in den letzten
jahren verdoppelt
ich bezweifle ich dass ich zum dorf
ziehen damit sich eine riester sparer
wurde mister sonders soziale themen in
andere dorffestes unterhalt und
minimierte und ich glaube wirklich dass
tegut paragrafen reiterei ohne augenmaß
oder gerechtfertigter druck ein
typischer konflikt zwischen
sozialhilfeempfängerin und gemeinde
langwierig nervenaufreibend
unbefriedigend das problem das
eigentlich konnten die gemeinderäte müse
finanzieren und das tut natürlich
pigment aber höhere sozialhilfequote hey
du dass der finanzielle druck geben
große stimme hören und das gibt es druck
auf sozialhilfe um den ich weiß richtig
wenn sie auf sichere euro wird die
sozialhilfe und vom bogen regler und der
feder der mechanismus für die definierte
für die hersteller so dass nicht der
insel nicht mehr übermäßig betroffen sie
und andere gar nicht
terrys schlepper will nicht dass sich
der bund einmischt im gegenteil sie
fordert mehr handlungsspielraum für die
gemeinden wenn der sozialhilfebezüger
zuerst motivation und kooperation zeigen
müsse bevor er die volle unterstützung
erhalte sei das effizienter als das
heutige strafsystem
warum regt euch da sowie der
sozialhilfebezieher erstens mac
praktisch freie hand hat oder nur ganz
schwierig und harz ich könnt die
leistungen kürzen
ich hätte eine strophe das und dann wenn
sie nicht kooperieren
dass man nicht leisten
aber es wäre sicher es wäre sicher für
steuerzahler gegenüber den mitarbeitern
die in der sozialhilfe schlepper fühlt
sich bestärkt von einer studie des
bundes wonach weniger sozialhilfe geld
vor allem junge menschen zur arbeit
bewegen kann
[Musik]
felix wolffers hat viele anpassungen in
der sozialhilfe mitgestaltet jetzt aber
ist er müde
seit fünf jahren ist er co präsident der
skos seit zehn jahren chef des berner
sozialamts in dieser zeit wurde die
politische diskussion hertha immer
wieder gab es schlagzeilen zum
sozialhilfe missbrauch begründet oder
unbegründet
der letzte sturm der entrüstung bei
einer sozialhilfe bezügerinnen wurden
nach dem tod säcke voller kleider
gefunden obwohl sich der fall als
haltlos erweisen sollte war wolf haas
tage lang gefordert korrekt für
sozialhilfe missbrauch
wenn sie fertig die berner
sozialdirektion reichte wegen dieses
falls beim presserat beschwerde ein und
bekam vollumfänglich recht der presserat
rügte den blick unter anderem wegen
verletzung der wahrheitspflicht die
berichterstattung über diesen fall sei
spekulativ und unwahr
die grenze des zulässigen überschritten
immer neue skandal schlagzeilen und
ständiger spardruck wolfers hat genug
er hat seinen rücktritt als präsident
angekündigt diskussionsführung angerer
sieht der gar keine sachliche argumente
vorschlägt kriegs prozent weniger aber
es geht dem rocker sachliche basis und
und das macht für mich extrem schwierig
sie birgt bewogen sachlich diskutiert um
was auch auseinandersetzt aber es fehlt
eine sachliche diskussion und romani
druck bedeutet sondern punkte hinter das
kaum mehr wettmachen
ich gebe gern das amt kam unter anderem
von bizerba processes doppelte belastung
wenn es etliche plastik und das ist eine
emotionale belastung
bis im mai ist felix wolffers an der
seite von therese frösch noch im amt als
co-präsident der skos an der
jahresmedienkonferenz in bern
präsentieren die beiden eine studie die
zeigt wie viel das leben wirklich kostet
für die ärmsten im land mit fakten will
die skos den kürzungsvorschlägen in den
kantonen entgegentreten eine solch
detaillierte analyse gab es bisher nicht
die die frage ist ja einfach wie weit
kann man mit großen kürzungen gehen und
da gibt es auch rechtliche schranken die
kantone sind verpflichtet die
grundrechte zu gewährleisten
sie müssen eine menschenwürdige existenz
sichern und man kann nicht einfach
beliebig tief aus finanzpolitischen
gründen bei baby tiefe grundbedarf werde
ansetzen
der grundbedarf orientiert sich an den
zehn prozent der einkommensschwächsten
haushalte diskurs studie kommt zum
schluss schon der aktuelle grundbedarf
reicht nur knapp zum leben ein
rechnerisch müsste ja höher liegen
kürzungen seien nicht vertretbar bedarf
erstellt jeder vierköpfige familie pro
tag mmcf lieber zur verfügung um 16
treffer für frank jacobs und vernünftige
5 franken pro tag und kopf für essen und
trinken das stimme nicht sagen die
beiden baselbieter svp politiker peter
regli und andy brüssel
es sei alles eine frage der einteilung
man könne zum beispiel mehr fürs essen
ausgeben und weniger fürs handy
30 prozent weniger sozialhilfe sei
machbar
was mir einfach spaß dann ist das ein
meter vor dem hörsaal gültiger
sozialhilfe liga 2 2 system i für das
ist eine überbrückungshilfe der liebste
möglichst schnell begrüßt mich wunderts
einfach das gros der richtlinie sauber
seit darf meine
ein trainings prozentige reduktion
möglichkeiten wenn sich nicht dort
komfort anfragte und denn sollte das
immer noch gut sie aber beim erben
industriestaaten und tv motiviert sind
wieder runter zu bringen ist dass
menschen unmöglich da nicht wissen wir
dass nachvollziehen für diskurs ist die
kürzung um 30 prozent nur zulässig als
zeitlich begrenzte sanktion
mit ihrer aktuellen studie will sie die
politische diskussion versachlichen
vorschlag diskutieren
das kann dazu führen dass das die
stimmung auseinanderbricht und was denn
passiert wo sie mir nicht
[Musik]
sozialhilfebezüger in karin de roche in
hagenbuch gemeindepräsident interesse
hat zu einem gemeinsamen test einkauf
eingewilligt um ihre liste zu erklären
[Musik]
karin dor will vor allem wissen wie sich
die günstigen preise auf der liste
zusammen setzen
ein stück käse pro tag 30 gramm zum
preis von 40 rappen hat te reh schlepper
zb berechnet wo gibt es diese kleinen
portionen wo diesen günstigen käse
braucht
ich habe keine kleine schnitte das ist
schon klar ob das team zum beispiel
richter und ich möchte dass sie anfangs
männer kaufen damit denn das
einigermaßen auf gott und das sind das
wirklich auch die preise sind dass sie
völlig einzelne produkt was halt 29 grad
beim ersten
auch wenn die rechnung auf dieser liste
für theres schlepper aufgeht karin dor
schlins iab untauglich für den alltag
sagt sie und die ganzen
kürzungsvorschläge eintreten nach unten
generalverdacht ich muss bewiesen dass
ich nichts falsch machen nur willig
abhängig für die sozialhilfe sind die
das schon erscheinen also
generalverdacht dass jetzt spreche ja es
wird ein kreuz und ich muss mich
bewiesen dass ich das ganz gut aber sie
wären uns gemeinsam für afrika
geschaffen
aber sie müssen sie heute pflicht ist es
behinderte troja den könne sogar nico
schafe den fall ist sowieso eine gruppe
wo man wahrscheinlich sagen er ist unter
der woche paar tage weg dahin nicht
zwingend ein paar takte eingeschlafen
also weniger maschine sicher vorschlag
könnte aber auch die einsicht
vorgeschlagen dass sie nahezu er wenn
der ez
die geplanten kürzungen würden leute wie
kalendarisch nicht treffen sagt theres
schläpfer doch die pläne sind klar
in einem ersten schritt gebe es weniger
für alle die bedürftigen müssten sich
dann beweisen
das bestrafte wo es betrifft um ihr vieh
und die sozialhilfeempfänger fühlen sich
abgestraft die gemeinden ohnmächtig der
finanzdruck macht sie zu gegenspielern
oder geht es gar nicht nur ums geld ist
es grundsätzlich schwer zu akzeptieren
dass jemand geld bekommt ohne dafür zu
arbeiten
in diesem jahr fallen in den kantonen
wegweisende entscheide wie viele
sozialhilfeempfänger haben dürfen
[Musik]